Your Dr. Connors is in okay to put the six drops in bio-sited. So this is a
bio-sited liquid in a little water instead of straight because what husband
says it burns. Also wanted to know your thoughts about the
treatment diet, the macias, earth or cancer or Candida. Thank you. Yeah, you can
use the bio-sited water. That's just so if you need to water it out or put it into
your drink or him, that's just fine. So that's that's good. Diatomaceous
earth that can be good for things in your gut. I would just suggest that you go
slow. A lot of a lot of things I like you'll hear that you're taking a table spoon
of diatomaceous earth a day. Don't ever start with that. Start with a half
a teaspoon and work your way up. So just start with every starting the new
supplement something like that. It isn't really technically a supplement. It's
trying to bind stuff in the gut. Help kill some parasites in the gut and things
that you want to just start slow. And then I wouldn't that be something that
does not take you know constantly. It's not something you take on a daily basis for
the rest of your life. You take that for a period of time and you go off and put
it for a period of time. So yes, it's okay to put the bile
side in water or in your drink. Diatomaceous earth is spied. It's not really a
cancer killer. It helps kill some things in the gut. But you just start real